il est 14 heures passées de quelques
minutes quand stéphanie policière de 49
ans et mère de deux enfants est tué de
plusieurs coups de couteau hier
le meurtre a eu lieu dans le sas
d'entrée du commissariat où elle
travaillait depuis plus de 20 ans
l'assassin présumé un tunisien en
situation régulière a été abattu par les
collègues de la victime
dès la fin de journée l' enquête sur les
motivations et les potentiels
complicités dont a bénéficié
l'assaillant a été confiée au parquet
national anti terroriste les raisons de
cette saisine sont les suivants en
premier le déroulement même des faits
qui comprend des éléments de repérage
également la réalisation d'effets
modalités mailles du crime la personne
de la victime mais aussi les propos
tenus par l'auteur au moment de la
réalisation des feux présent sur les
lieux
jean castex a tenu à inscrire cet acte
dans la lignée des précédents
une nouvelle fois le département des
yvelines est mis à rude épreuve des
attaques terroristes
puisque nous avons tous en mémoire
l'odieux attentat de magnanville en 2016
et plus récemment l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit il y a cinq ans
la police de vivre line était déjà
touché en plein coeur dans leur pavillon
de magnanville jessica schnyder et son
mari tous deux policiers au commissariat
des mureaux mouret poignardé leurs
agresseurs laroussi abdallah islamistes
radicalisées a grandi dans les environs
il sera abattu alors qu'il s'est
retranché dans le pavillon de ses
victimes en octobre dernier à conflans
sainte honorine toujours dans les
yvelines
la décapitation de samuel pâtit secoue
la france toute entière
le professeur a été tué par un exilés
tchétchènes pour avoir montré à ses
élèves les caricatures du prophète
mahomet publiée par charlie hebdo